[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
25 novembre bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
voici lé titre j - à 31 pour les fêtes
de fin d'année noël approche à grands
pas et les communes de saint quentin en
yvelines se prépare pour l'événement les
décorations de noël sont en cours
d'installation vous le verrez eux
arrivent au bout de leur course alain
juppé françois fillon s'oppose dans les
urnes ce dimanche pour le second tour de
la primaire de la droite et du centre
ghislain fournier maire de château et
soutien d'alain juppé notre invité fil
rouge pour cette émission enfin dans le
reste de l'actualité nous reviendrons
sur le lancement de la campagne des
restos du coeur ou la lutte contre le
tabagisme avec le mois sans tabac qui se
termine fin novembre mais on ouvre ce
journal avec les chiffres du chômage ils
sont stables dans le département des
yvelines au mois d'octobre un peu plus
de 64 mille personnes sont inscrites en
catégorie a dans le département c'est à
dire qu'elles n'exercent aucune activité
sur trois mois sur les trois derniers
mois ce chiffre est en baisse de 1 avec
le 4 % en revanche sur une année
complète légère augmentation de ce
chiffre de 0,1 pour cent dans un autre
registre les fêtes de noël approchent à
grands pas je vous le disais en titre le
rush pour les cadeaux on a déjà a débuté
les communes elles aussi s'organisent
pour les fêtes de fin d'année en ce
moment les illuminations sont installés
c'est le cas par exemple à coignard aux
clayes-sous-bois reportage de nicolas
landry et mélanie poké
dans un mois c'est noël et les communes
sont à pied d'oeuvre pour installer les
dernières décorations à coignières 110
installations ont été montés par les
agents municipaux coût total dix mille
euros pour la municipalité à coignières
nous maîtrisons en totalité la révision
des décorations de noël la création
également et la pause ce qui nous permet
de bien maîtriser de a à z à un coût
tout à fait raisonnable et et encore une
fois de qualité grâce aux ateliers
municipaux qui oeuvre en permanence là
dessus aux clayes-sous-bois
l'installation est externalisée
illuminations sur la mairie et les
lampadaires boules de neige dans les
arbres ou encore 80 sapins sont répartis
dans les rues de la ville des points de
vue financier on a diminué entre
2011 2015 nous étions aux environs de
50000 euros qu'on investisse et
maintenant on a diminué on est plus qu à
40000 euros
autre économie on a plus de lampes
incandescentes on n'a que des leds les
différentes décorations on les choisit
en fonction des lieux où on voit les
poser quand on a une zone alors on a
ciblé les zones commerciales pour mettre
en valeur les commerces surtout dans
cette période festive de noël le
lancement des illuminations aux
clayes-sous-bois se fera le 5 décembre
et à partir du 16 une patinoire sera
ouverte sur le parvis de la mairie
[Musique]
et l'actualité de la semaine est
forcément politique et pour en parler
avec nous si cela fournit est notre
invité fil rouge bonsoir bonsoir
ghislain fournier vous êtes le maire de
château vice présidente de conseil
départemental des yvelines et soutien
inconditionnel déjà depuis deux ans
d'alain juppé pour cette campagne des
primaires votre titre exact c'est vous
êtes au responsable on va dire des
comités alain juppé dans les yvelines
tessa bien ça on va débuter forcément
avec le débat qui a eu lieu jeudi soir
dernière oral avant le second tour ce
dimanche comment vous avez trouvé votre
favori avoue alain juppé on l'a dit un
peu en haut un peu timide au début du
débat est-ce que c'est regard que vous
portez dessus aussi égoutter moi j'ai
trouvé globalement que les deux
candidats avaient été bons tous les deux
qu'ils ont montré tous les deux qu'ils
avaient la stature et j'ai trouvé alain
juppé plus précis sur le détail sur la
mise en forme ouais on prédisait avant
le débat un débat peut être très très
s'invectivent yeux entre 2 et finalement
il ya eu un certain niveau dans ce débat
c'est rassurant voilà sert à se parler
du fond on a pu vraiment parler du fond
mais à mon sens
les lavandes et bat le questionnement
d'alain juppé à françois fillon était
clairement dans le cadre d'une campagne
électorale classique d'un débat
politique tout à fait normal et
je n'ai pas compris qu'on puisse dire
qu' il y avait eu des tensions puisque
alain juppé a posé des questions à
demander des éclaircissements et c'est
bien normal dans un débat politique vous
pensez que ce débat peut inverser la
tendance concrètement pour alain juppé
que sur un débat on peut tout bousculer
tout chambouler moi je pense que sur un
débat on ne peut pas tout bousculer tout
chambouler je pense plutôt que ce
deuxième tour rebat les cartes rebat
clairement les cartes parce que vous
aurez des électeurs qui ne sont pas
venus qui viendront peut-être plus
d'électeurs peut-être moins d'électeurs
et que globalement tout reste possible
sur ce deuxième débat sur ce deuxième
scrutin repli de flux plus généralement
comment comment vont les troupes dans
les yvelines après ce premier tour et ce
score un peu décevant ou pour alain
juppé largement distancé par françois
fillon vous avez réussi à remobiliser
tout le monde c'est vrai que le soir du
premier tour on a pris un coup sur la
tête 28% pour allart pkr en pensez pas
on pensait pas qu alain juppé
serez que plus tôt que françois fillon
serait si roucou - voilà après
voilà on est reparti au combat dès lundi
et mardi toute la semaine les comités
alain juppé dans les yvelines notamment
ont été très actifs cette semaine sur
toutes les gares surtout des marchés ils
seront encore là demain et on y croit
bien sûr et qui est le vrai retour avec
les gens que vous disent les gens et
bien écoutez voilà il n'y a pas de
tension il ya vraiment pas de tension
les gens soient ils prennent ils
prennent pas et disent bonjour oui ça va
le faire non je suis plutôt pour fillon
voilà mais le débat dans les yvelines en
tout cas sur le terrain il n'est pas
tendu il et il est vraiment il est
vraiment serein parce que chacun sait et
moi le premier qu'il faudra se retrouver
le lendemain du second tour dans les
yvelines justement les soutiens d'un à
juppé étaient nombreux le soutien
politique malgré cela à françois fillon
a rassemblé dans le département près de
49% des voix contre 29 pour alain juppé
comment vous expliquez à voir que alain
juppé avait quasiment tous les soutiens
yvelinois qui a un tel écart entre entre
les deux et notamment dans les yvelines
c'est plus que d'un point de vue
national mon analyse c'est que la
campagne
de françois fillon qui était on va dire
plus conservatrice et je pèse mes mots
et ce n'est pas un mot show conan débat
politique correspondaient sans doute
mieux à ce que souhaitait les yvelinois
les passants sur les élus ce qui a
forcément les il entend forcément les
élus peut-être que voilà les élus qui
soutenait alain juppé sont sans doute
plus réformateurs
voilà et que la majorité de la
population
qui a voté en tout cas celle qui a voté
peut-être pas la majorité de la
population est en tout cas celle qui a
voté c'est la partie plutôt
conservatrice de notre électorat qui a
voté qui est plutôt favorable alain
juppé à françois fillon c'est vrai en
tout cas hâter les fils est allé
demander à des saint quentinois ce
qu'ils allaient voter dimanche pour ce
second tour et coûté leur réponse
je trouve que jp exprime pas forcément
toutes ces idées ou du moins ne va pas
jusqu'au bout et il a été trop critique
par rapport au programme que ce soit par
à fillon il s'attaque à françois
hollande par rapport à son à sa vie
personnelle alors que ça regarde
personne au final je préfère filer ou
quand même dans le pire des cas bon
parce que je pense que c'est quelqu'un
qui assume et ce qu'il a dit et qui
resteront malgré tout discret celui que
je préfère quand même moi je suis plutôt
fillon et pourquoi pas ce que c'est
s'il est susceptible de faire les
réformes nécessaires pour la france je
ferais je pense pour fillon
pourquoi
pour son programme pour ses idées pour
ce qu'il a envie de tout ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire pour pour la france j'ai
voté sarko parce que j'étais de brossard
comme et je préfère la deuxième touche
préfères
tu préfères monsieur fillon monsieur
juppé alors évidemment ghislain fournier
ce ne sont que quelques avis hein c'est
pas un sondage très poussées mais quand
vous voyez ces réponses est ce que vous
êtes toujours confiant à 100% écoutez
moi une vraie dynamique qui s'installe
et quand même du côté françois fillon
moi j'ai fait du terrain ce matin j'ai
fait une gare le rer à la gare de chatou
croissy hier également et j'ai trouvé
que les avis étaient beaucoup plus
partagés que ce que on a pas de fichier
mais les réponses qu'on avait nous fait
on a eu un peu de mal d'ailleurs à
trouver des réponses à chaque fois les
gens n'allaient pas forcément voté et
ceux qui allaient voter à chaque fois
ont répondu fillon je ne vous fais aucun
procès d'intention je vous préviens
volontiers bon voilà peut-être que dans
certains endroits des yvelines où le
matin les gens sont plus lucides on a
entendu de trois personnes dire dans ce
micro trottoir juppé trop flou trop vers
le centre fillon plus radicale est ce
qu'il n'ya pas eu aussi une taille et
une erreur tactique de la part d'alain
juppé pendant la campagne de prendre un
peu de hauteur et ne pas répondre aux
attaques des trains peu dans le flou
dans son de temps en temps on peut le
dire est ce qu'une erreur une mauvaise
campagne alors alain juppé le dit
lui-même il
ne pensait pas que les attaques dont il
a fait l'objet pendant des semaines et
des semaines d' attaques anonymes
odieuse sur les réseaux sociaux le
traitant de salafistes et de même d'anti
de proche des frères musulmans a été une
campagne qui a fait du mal puisque
moi-même on m'en a parlé donc elle a
impacté et aurait dû répondre il aurait
vous répondre sans doute de façon plus
forte et plus tôt il l'a très bien fait
au moment du débat mais c'est vrai que
ça a impacté et ça décrédibilise et on
est assez scandalisé par par ces
attaques anonymes voilà qui ne reflète
absolument pas la personnalité et les
options politiques d'ailleurs hier enfin
jeudi soir lors du lors du débat alain
juppé s'est aussi montré on va dire pas
forcément très percutant une nouvelle
fois est ce que vous auriez souhaité
qu'il aille peut être plus fort plus
loin sur non moi en tout cas sur ce
sujet là il a dit les choses clairement
il a dit voilà j'ai été j'ai été attaqué
j'ai pas entendu les lieutenants des uns
et des autres me défendre
alors que ces attaques monde est servi
j'aurais souhaité plus de solidarité
face à des attaques aussi ignominieux et
finalement c'est sa nature alain juppé
c'est ce que vous sous entendez il n'est
pas forcément quelqu'un de virulent dans
ses propos voilà alain juppé quelqu'un
de posé de mesuré dans ses propos
il a une volonté de changement très
forte mais il a de la méthode et il
explose de façon posée ghislain fournier
écoutez maintenant jean frédéric poisson
député des yvelines candidat malheureux
à cette primaire il était jeudi soir sur
notre plateau il a évoqué son soutien à
françois fillon
il y aura sans doute des ajustements
possibles
et je pense qu'il en faudra parce que
comment dire le jeu reste très
interrogatif sur
la
possibilité pour notre pays et pour les
français de supporter une austérité qui
me paraît décalée par rapport à ce qu'on
peut effectivement être capable
d'accueillir dans la situation du pays
aujourd'hui maintenant ce qui rassemble
de projet permet je crois malgré tout
envisager une coopération fructueuse
alors jean frédéric poisson président du
parti chrétien démocrate qui soutient
françois fillon mais qui le dit lui-même
et il n'est pas sûr que le remède
françois fillon soit forcément acceptée
par les français c'est ce que dit aussi
alain juppé est ce que sur le fond
fillon juppé ces deux programmes très
différents
ou alors opposé ou alors finalement on
n'est pas très loin en or deux en série
de projets cetc ne sont pas des
programmes opposé mais il y a quand même
des différences des clivages assez fort
sur quels points notamment à prendre et
un point sur la protection sociale la
sécurité sociale pour moi c'est un
acquis fondamental
de la république de la nation l'ensemble
des pays du monde entier nous l'envient
et je ne pense pas qu'il faille remettre
en cause la sécurité sociale et françois
fillon dans ses propositions de
non-remboursement de beaucoup de
médicaments notamment tout ce qui est
grippe gastro otites au rayon des
enfants
est transféré ce remboursement au
secteur privé pour le déremboursés de la
sécurité sociale je pense que
c'est une atteinte qui n'est pas neutre
et alain juppé n'est pas du tout sur
cette petite position il est sur une
potée de position de protection des
citoyens au regard de la santé pour
faire en sorte que ceux qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de payer une mutuelle puisse
se soigner aussi bien que ceux qui le
peuvent quels sont les autres grands
marqueurs selon vous qui différencie
françois fillon et alain juppé on a
beaucoup parlé des fonctionnaires ils
veulent tous les deux souris mais des
postes de fonctionnaires c'est pas dans
la même ampleur 500 milles pour françois
fillon de 250 pour alain juppé voilà
vous l'avais dit à mon avis je pense
véritablement aussi comme alain juppé
que c'est trop brutale et que ça ne se
fera pas 500 milles je n'y crois pas on
ne peut pas ne pas remplacer des
infirmières des policiers
des dents la justice où l'on manque
énormément de moyens ça me paraît
totalement une posture politique
absolument est réalisable on verra dans
cinq ans c'est pour ça qu alain juppé
lui propose la moitié de suppression
pour les cd marge laissée de la
respiration au secteur sur les 35 heures
ont aussi eu pas mal de désaccord jeudi
soir françois fillon propose que tous
les personnels publics passent aux 39
heures payées 37 là aussi il ya la rai
et aurait il ya un vrai clivage alain
juppé pense qu'il n'est absolument pas
possible de passer de 35 36 à 39
directement dans la fonction publique du
jour au lendemain mais lui aussi veut
abroger les 35 heures il veut abroger
les freins cinq heures mais ils veulent
faire dans la négociation et sur une
plus longue durée passer de 35 à 39 dans
la fonction publique sur une année c'est
un coût pour les communes et pour le
budget des collectivités locales et le
budget d'état absolument insupportable
surtout au moment où les taux d'intérêt
commencent à remonter c'est
insupportable pour le budget de l'état
c'est pour ça que il me semble que la
proposition d'alain juppé est beaucoup
plus réaliste en tout cas vous êtes vous
aussi maire maire de chatou donc élu
local les deux les deux candidats
proposent des coupes budgétaires encore
pour les collectivités est ce que ça
vous inquiète même si vous êtes un
soutien dans la jupe est est ce que
parfois essayé d'influencer un peu sa
position là dessus alors écouter la
proposition d'alain juppé que je connais
bien c'est fait un pacte un pacte avec
les collectivités locales dire c'est du
donnant donnant voilà vous réduisez vous
réduisez votre fonctionnement vous
arrivez à réduire encore vous les
collectivités on a déjà fond on a déjà
longtemps souvent les mères dire c'est
plus possible quand c'est la gauche et
là on commence à entendre on peut on
continuer un peu on a déjà fait beaucoup
on commence à être à loos après si cet
impact que parce l'état de confiance
avec les collectivités en disant allez
plutôt dans ce sens et si vous nous
montrez que vous allez dans le sens on
maintient les les dotations vos dotation
et on les lice sur les quatre ans qui
viennent pour nous c'est absolument
fondamental parce qu'on a besoin de
visibilité et on ne l'a pas eue depuis
les cinq dernières années avec les
coupes sombres qui se sont succédé année
après année du gouvernement lord quoi
qu'il advienne votre famille politique
dimanche sera réuni peu importe le
vainqueur vous en êtes sûr de ça oui oui
oui j'en suis sûr nous nous réunirons
derrière le vainqueur de la primaire
c'était la règle du jeu de la primaire
et on le fera sans état d'âme merci
beaucoup ghislain fournier on referme
cette page politique avec le lancement
mardi dernier de la 32ème campagne
d'hiver des restos du coeur l'an passé
plus de neuf cent mille personnes ont
été accueillies dans les antennes
partout en france cette année les
bénévoles attendent la même affluence
nous sommes allés au centre de la
verrière suivre la distribution camille
lambert et patrick jacques de dixmude
pour les images
féculents produits laitiers ou d'hygiène
des produits de première nécessité mais
aujourd'hui encore tout le monde n'y a
pas accès les restos du coeur lancent
leur 32e campagne hivernale dans ce
centre de la verrière 25 bénévoles
viennent en aide aux personnes en
difficulté
pour cette mère de famille c'est la
première fois qu'elles bénéficient de ce
soutien je vais c'est qu'on cherche donc
utile la nourriture
ce qui nous a aidées pour faire
comme il n'ya pas de travail on
travaille pas on vient ici nouveau c'est
qu'il est maltraité c'est la première
fois je viens ici on a bien accueilli
pour le moment le centre compte une
cinquantaine d'inscrits l'été dernier il
a enregistré une augmentation de 9 % des
bénéficiaires mères célibataires
familles dans le besoin et étrangers
sans ressources tous les profils sont
prises en charge c'est là le profil si
je puis dire la typologie des personnes
qu'on accueille qui évolue un peu dans
la mesure où on
et évidemment
des personnes
ce lent en demande d'asile par exemple
c'est sûr qu'on leur apporte un soutien
mais pas seulement alimentaire pas
seulement administratives pas seulement
vestimentaires c'est des gens qui
viennent ici pour parler pour rencontrer
l'hiver dernier le centre de la verrière
a aidé 114 familles les bénévoles en
attendent au moins autant la campagne
d'hiver va durer quatre mois l'an
dernier les restos du coeur ont
distribué plus de 130 millions de repas
dans toute la france
le mois sans tabac arrive bientôt à son
terme cette initiative portée par le
ministère de la santé consiste à
encourager les fumeurs à arrêter
définitivement la cigarette pendant un
mois cela permettrait d'arrêter ensuite
de multiplier par cinq les chances
d'arrêter ensuite totalement la
cigarette au centre hospitalier de
versailles un service tabacologie existe
depuis le début des années 2000 nous
avons assisté à l'une de ces
consultations reportage
de semaine avec un patch une bonne dose
de volonté et l envie de retrouver un
souffle normal s'il ya 20 ans a décidé
d'arrêter de fumer progressivement de 15
à 8 cigarettes par jour une évolution
positive est importante même si les
difficultés le sont aussi mais sans
respirer je me sens humaine et et voilà
les difficultés face aux lyonnais a tout
le temps il y en a partout et dans tous
les domaines
et voilà ça fait partie de du sevrage
que ce soit tabagique alcoolique de
toute drogue donc il ya des difficultés
mais quand on atteint un objectif on est
hyper content pour réussir son pari
célia consulte le service tabacologie du
centre hospitalier de versailles une
aide est essentielle qui doit lui
permettre d'éviter la rechute à long
terme moi je prenais cigarette comme une
amie vraiment c'était vraiment je l'âge
la gym jeu l'humaniser et et
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas facile de
séparer d'une amie quand il ya des
rechutes elle est essentiellement due à
la dépendance psychologique c'est à dire
que la dépendance physique et
a disparu la dépendance comportementale
aussi est il ya une émotion qui va
revenir et qui va faire rejeter les
spécialistes parlent d'art et confirmé
après deux ans sans cigarettes chaque
année en france 73 mille personnes
décèdent à cause du tabac
un portrait également dans l'actualité à
villepreux se trouve peut-être la future
star mondiale du maquillage l'yvelinois
zh perrine allouche étudiante au lycée
florian a soit été élu meilleur apprenti
de france devant un jury de
professionnels rencontre avec michael et
demi d'euros
quand on y repense c'était trop bien à
première vue perrine la louche est une
étudiante comme les autres mais cette
ville proviennent de 17 ans a créé la
sensation dans le monde du maquillage en
devenant meilleur apprenti de france en
octobre dernier avec son dessin sur le
thème du dragon chinois elle a
véritablement enflammé le jury une
grande émotion pour la jeune fille
repenser tout ce qu'on a travaillé les
plans tout les mois où on s'est entraîné
avec mon professeur modèle même une
autre fille de ma classe qui a aussi
parcouru est comme moi le concours du
coup d'en repenser à tout ça et vas-y
que maintenant on arrivé là et du coup
ça fait bizarre vous aimez le court ici
pourtant cette yvelinoise n'est pas né
avec cette passion dans la peau le
maquillage et commencé quand je suis
rentré en seconde au lycée avant je
m'intéressais pas tellement c'était
plutôt les ongles que je faisais et
c'est après avec les cours ça m'a donné
encore plus envie de le faire et le
concours du coup ça ça m'a vraiment
donné encore plus envie de m'y
intéresser vingt six ans avant d'arriver
au strass et aux paillettes d'un titre
de meilleur apprenti perrine allouche a
répété ses gammes dans cette salle de
classe du lycée des métiers florian aso
c'est ici que j'ai été formé c'est ici
qu'on voulait d'entraînement donc à ma
professeur madame st martin donc c'est
ici que tout a commencé en fait dans la
structure la ville proviennent a pu
bénéficier des conseils de son
enseignante miley saint-martin meilleur
ouvrier de france 1015 dans la section
esthétique art du maquillage pour elle
le succès de sa protégée ne fait aucun
doute elle est minutieuse dans ce
qu'elle fait et en esthétique il il faut
cette qualité là et elle est toujours
agréable en cours et voilà le travail
très bien des qualités qui pourraient
comme dans ses rêves les plus fous l'a
propulsé comme maquilleuse sur des
défilés français et internationaux dans
les années à venir j'ai beaucoup
d'objectifs en fait je veux pas faire
qu'une chose dans ma vie je sais que
j'ai envie de travailler en maquillage
de scène maquillage artistique
pourquoi pas être professeur aussi mais
avant de penser à l'avenir perrine devra
obtenir son bac pro en juin prochain un
examen moins glamour qu'un titre
d'apprentis mais qui lui ouvrira les
portes du monde du travail
on referme ce journal en culture cette
année l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines mis sur le futur l'espace et
la conquête spatiale avec de nombreuses
expositions sur ces thématiques c'est le
cas par exemple à la commanderie des
templiers d'elancourt l'infini intime du
gouverneur vous prouve que l'art et les
mathématiques peuvent faire un tour
camille lambert et mélanie poké
allergique aux mathématiques ne fuyait
pas c'est derviches sont des croquis la
base du travail de gouvernance le
plasticien français on fait de l'art de
laruns numérique
c'est une passion c'est j'ai commencé
sans même imaginer que j'étais dans une
démarche artistique j'avais vraiment à
coeur une recherche
le désir de découvrir ou de mener ce
matériau
[Musique]
une fascination pour les groupes depuis
l'enfance donc je vois de l'infini dans
les caussinus les sinus les logarithmes
et les exponentielle et j'ai commencé
vraiment très tôt a commencé à combiner
ces ce matériau des oeuvres infini à la
vie autonome hugo verlinde de créer des
codes permettant de développer des
univers propre comme ceux lotus réalisé
en lycra exposé pour la première fois
[Musique]
c'est un rêve c'est un rêve le point de
départ du lotus c'est je me suis vu
dans une pièce un peu comme ici une
grande pièce que beaucoup d'espacé des
auteurs et en me baladant
j'étais face à un énorme pétales qui
avoue qu'elle avait exactement donc
cette forme qu'on voit là et j'en
faisais le tour et je découvrais une
projection sur sur un pétale jeux de
lumière et sensation d'espacé un film
hugo verlinde vous entraîne dans un
voyage numérique
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci de
nous avoir suivis vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission pote cas sur tv fil 78
points comme bon week-end à tous et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]